President Trump is still telling NFL
sideline protesters they're wrong he
tweeted minutes ago that kneeling has
nothing to do with race it's about
respect for our country flag and
national anthem NFL players join pregame
protests yesterday from London to Los
Angeles it was a response to the
president saying players should be fired
for kneeling during the anthem the
demonstrations started last year to
protest police brutality and racism many
teams locked arms in a show of unity
more than 200 players knelt or sat
during the anthem only six players
protested a week ago before the
president's comments Super Bowl MVP Tom
Brady was one of those locking arms
yesterday and spoke about the
president's comments in a radio
interview I certainly disagree with you
know what he said and and you know
thought it was just divisive and and you
know like I said it's you know I just
want to support my teammate CBS News
special correspondent James Brown has
hosted the NFL today on CBS he joins us
now from Washington JB good morning
Charlie good morning to you Nora and
Gayle tell us what you saw as you
watched and what you thought as you
watched this weekend
what I saw was an example of
togetherness I mean football is the
ultimate team sport so I saw owners the
Commissioner NFL PA director and players
all in unison not necessarily agreeing
with the method that some of the players
are taking but certainly an effort to
hear what they're saying charlie and
that it is not anti flag it is more Pro
the issues that have been
well-documented and long-standing and
trying to find a solution together and I
think James that's what's concerning a
lot of people that they're missing the
message about how this originally
started that it didn't start as a
campaign against the country or
patriotism Gail not at all again we
talked about the kind of issues that are
systemic that a long-standing and
well-documented in communities of color
especially in terms of a racial
inequality and these players by the way
Gail aren't just making a statement most
of these players have been actively
engaged in trying to improve the fabric
of those communities
with their actions and with their
dollars so certainly they're to be
commended in that regard well this
started with Colin Kaepernick over a
year ago and many people didn't support
him at that time publicly why do you
think now is different after after
President Trump's words well I think and
I have yet to talk to Colin Kaepernick
so let me be clear about that but from
what he said before in the early days of
this in 2016 is that he wanted to raise
the level of awareness and try to engage
civil dialogue amongst not a homogenous
group of people inclusive and diverse to
try to deal with the problems and
unfortunately through all of the rancor
and vitriol that's been spewed out since
then at least it's now in the public
consciousness and people are having
conversations across different strata if
you will to try to find out what the
solution is some fans say they
appreciate the players right to protest
but that it shouldn't come during the
national anthem what do you make of that
you know noir and I and I truly
completely understand how many people
only see the flag and what it stands for
and think that is a it is an affront to
of those in law enforcement and military
it's not anti any of those things it's
more Pro what the issues are and I think
to the degree the old expression can we
can we reason together sit down to hear
one another and that's what we're seeing
when we look at people like Arthur Blank
ownership like Arthur Blank like Steven
Ross with the Miami Dolphins Pete
Carroll the coach of the Seattle
Seahawks they are at least engaged in
dialogue they're hearing the players to
be supportive look the old expression
you can agree to disagree without being
disagreeable is the manner in which
they're going about it Nora where's
Colin Kapernick I in a year later a year
later still from a visible standpoint
unemployed as far as the NFL is
concerned and that's another hold issue
but Charlie the one thing I have to give
him credit for even though I might
choose a different course of action
myself the fact of the matter is he's
committed he's put his money where his
mouth is nearly a million dollars to
community efforts to be a bridge builder
and he's personally been out there doing
it so he's not just someone sitting up
living comfortably off of his money and
talking about an issue he's out there on
the frontlines and he's involved maybe
many people would select to see him play
thank you very much James Brown thank
you guys